l'épilepsie est un mal invisible
isabelle méline s'est aperçue que son
fils théo souffrait d'épilepsie à l'âge
de 7 ans et demi la cause une tumeur
cérébrale
c'est alors le cri d'une maman pour
toutes les autres mamans isabelle méline
devient la correspondante locale des
yvelines de l'association épilepsie
france car souvent les familles se
retrouvent isolés face à la maladie
s'ajoutent l'éloignement par manque de
prise en charge en ile-de-france des
épileptiques pour notre fils théo il a
d'abord vécu à l'hôpital ici à un but
lyon pendant trois ans et après il n'y
avait plus rien pour lui on a dû le
mettre dans un centre spécialisé pour
l'épilepsie en bretagne et suite à la
bretagne
il s'est retrouvé sur toulouse et c'est
là qu'il a préparé un bac professionnel
en gestion administration penser que ça
aurait pu aller mais l'épilepsie
vraiment difficile à livrer c'est
impossible qu'il puisse continuer en
gardant bien de le dire
il faisait que c'est victor par semaine
mais malgré ça c'est à l'allègement et
encore des crises qui sont trop
présentes qui peut pas suivre et prend
trop de retard on aurait aimé faire
différent mais c'est impossible de faire
c'est en tout cas pour l'instant dans
les yvelines deuxième pathologies
neurologiques en france les médecins
traitent l'épilepsie mais pas les
répercussions sur la vie sociale des
malades sont fatigués
les chris martin ça m'empêche énormément
bas d'être vraiment ifa du coup je
m'endors concours très vite donc les
utiliser les activités ses scoops
c'est tellement que social
le combat n'est pas terminé pour la mère
et son fils ils se battent pour une
meilleure prise en charge de cette
maladie au sein de la société notamment
dans les écoles